[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute nutzbar
war guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
wahlsonntag hat ja strehse ist auch
dabei erstmals ohne medaille aus peking
aber um viele gute leistungen absolut
der alte und neue bundespräsident setzt
direkt zeichen
wer für die demokratie streitet der hat
mich auf seiner seite
wer sie angreift wird mich als gegner
haben
steinmeier zum zweiten der
bundespräsident ist wiedergewählt und
wirbt für mut und frieden
sorge vor einer eskalation während
russland die warnungen vor einem krieg
in der ukraine hysterie nennt üben
zivilisten dort die landesverteidigung
und ernüchterung bei den biathleten in
den verfolgungsrennen laufen die
deutschen teams männer wie frauen der
olympischen konkurrenz hinterher
frank walter steinmeier bleibt also
höchster repräsentant des staates die
bundesversammlung bestätigte ihn im
ersten wahlgang als bundespräsident für
den 66 jährigen stimmten
1045 teilnehmer fast drei viertel der
gültigen stimmen max otte aufgestellt
von der afg erhielt 140 stimmen gerhard
trabert der kandidat der linken 96 auf
stephanie bauer freie wähler entfielen
58 stimmen weniger hat mehr
es kommt so wie es erwartet worden war
und darüber freuen sich die den alten
zum neuen bundespräsidenten gewählt
haben frank walter steinmeier 66 jahre
alt wird weiterhin an der spitze des
staates stehen er verspricht für die
demokratie zu kämpfen aus ihm spricht
heute aber auch überraschend deutlich
der ehemalige außenminister klartext
richtung russland
präsident den lösen sie die schlinge um
den hals der ukraine suchen sie mit uns
seinen weg der frieden in europa bewahrt
eine wiederwahl in ungewöhnlichem
ambiente wegen corona nicht im
plenarsaal des bundestags sondern nach
button abgeordnetenhaus
1472 delegierte aus politik und
gesellschaft von denen sich fast drei
viertel hinter steinmeier versammeln
eine frauen zwei weitere männer waren
auch zur wahl angetreten den mediziner
georg trabert spricht steinmeier
persönlich an das thema obdachlosigkeit
beschäftigt uns beide sie wissen es seit
langer zeit warum schauen wir nicht ob
wir diesen drängenden thema
gemeinsam mehr aufmerksamkeit
verschaffen können aber ich würde mich
freuen wenn wir darüber ins gespräch
geben ein kandidat er ein thema gesetzt
hat die first lady elke büdenbender
setzt auf 1 sie will in teilzeit wieder
als richterin arbeiten ob ihr mann
bundespräsident der klaren worte werden
will beantwortet er der zdf sendung was
nun klare ansagen ganz sicher man kann
sie nicht jeden tag machen man muss
darauf achten dass man gerührt wird
deshalb habe ich immer sehr darauf
geachtet dass ich als bundespräsident
nicht als der tägliche besserwisser
wahrgenommen werde fünf weitere jahre
für frank walter steinmeier demokratie
verteidigen nicht nur die deutsche dazu
hat er sich hier heute verpflichtet
theo koll in berlin das waren schon auf
fand deutliche worte vom
bundespräsidenten heute oder ja das war
ungewöhnlich deutlich und das war wenn
mir das urteil erlaubt sei eine seiner
großen reden er hat in der ukraine krise
absoluten klartext geredet russland
trage die verantwortung für die krise
und er hat putin gewandt der solle nicht
den fehler machen die stärke der
demokratie zu unterschätzen also das war
an deutlichkeit kaum zu überbietender
ist ein bundespräsident bis an die
grenze aktiver politik gegangen das war
eine rede die auch ein bundeskanzler
hätte halten können und gleichzeitig hat
er für seine zweite amtszeit kontinuität
angekündigt in seinem klaren einsatz für
demokratie und hat auch da steinmeier an
schärfe zugelegt er werde keine
kontroverse scheuen wer die demokratie
angreifen wir haben sie eben gehört der
habe ihn zum gegner also steinmeier zwei
wird vertraut und zugleich neue die
einsetzung von theora vielen dank nach
berlin
was nun herr steinmeier fragen an den
bundespräsidenten zu sehen gleich nach
uns außerdem finden sie die komplette
rede von frank walter steinmeier und
weitere hintergründe zur wahl in der
zdf- heute- app
mitten in der aufgeheizten lage reist
der bundeskanzler morgen zunächst in die
ukraine übermorgen weiter nach moskau im
ringen um eine friedliche lösung des
konflikt die usa befürchten dass ein
angriff russlands auf die ukraine
unmittelbar bevorstehen könne
christiansen über die aktuelle situation
auf der anderen seite der grenze läuft
das russisch wähler russische
militärmanöver in belarus sehen oder
hören kann man es nicht doch auch im
grenzdorf der banker machen sich die
menschen sorgen dass es wirklich eine
invasion russlands geben wird glauben
sie nicht
wenn es einen krieg geben wird dann
werde ich ihnen das schon sagen nicht
eine rakete wird zu uns fliegen
und während russlands militär die
muskeln spielen lässt laufen weiter die
drähte heiss in der krisendiplomatie und
die usa erneut die warnung vor einer
russischen invasion aber ohne konkrete
beweise vorzulegen
wir glauben dass es jetzt jeden tag zu
einer größeren militäraktion kommen
könnte und wieder kommen diese
einschätzung aus einer vielzahl von
quellen und nicht nur vom geheimdienst
morgen reist bundeskanzler scholz zuerst
nach kiew und dann weiter nach moskau
mit dem ziel klare ansagen in hinblick
auf das was passiert im falle einer
militärischen aggression und
gleichzeitig alle wege nutzen die
möglich sind dafür dass es zu einer
friedlichen entwicklung aus der krise
herauskommt und dass russland die
situation deeskaliert einen krieg mit
den nachbarn in der ukraine wir fragen
in moskau was die russinnen und russen
darüber denken ich hoffe dass sich alles
zum guten wendet aber von putin ist
nichts gutes zu erwarten
der völlig den verstand verloren
das hätte konsequenzen viele menschen
wären betroffen
es würde viele opfer geben und in einer
katastrophe enden
und in der ukraine wie hier in odessa
bereiten sich freiwillige weiter auf das
szenario vor von dem alle hoffen dass es
nicht eintritt
der blick auf die deutschen corona
zahlen lässt hoffen dass das ende der
omicron welle in sicht ist zum ersten
mal seit beginn des rasanten anstiegs
ende dezember sinkt die sieben tage
incidents sie liegt heute bei 1400 66,5
bei den neuinfektionen scheint sich der
abwärtstrend der letzten tage zu
stabilisieren
125.000 160 wurden im
robert-koch-institut binnen 24 stunden
gemeldet
8013 weniger als vor einer woche
58 todesfälle kamen hinzu
fast zwei jahre pandemie schüren
offenbar das fernweh der deutschen
jedenfalls sind jedenfalls sind die
buchungszahlen für die kommende
urlaubssaison hoch die lufthansa
verzeichnet eine stark steigende
nachfrage nach flügen besonders auf
touristischen strecken innerhalb europas
das sagte ein vorstandsmitglied der bild
am sonntag es gebe einen enormen
nachholbedarf auch beim
reiseveranstalter tui gingen für dieses
jahr bereits so viele buchungen ein wie
vor koroma
jetzt zu dir katja heute ein tag ohne
olympia medaillen für deutschland das
stimmt leider und das kommt aber
insbesondere im biathlon auch nicht
überraschend denn die ergebnisse in den
letzten rennen waren einfach nicht gut
genug bester deutscher im heutigen
verfolgungsrennen war roman rees auf
platz sechs keine einfachen verhältnisse
für die deutschen biathleten beim
verfolgungsrennen immerhin der von platz
17 gestartete schwarzwälder roman ries
konnte nach einer starken aufholjagd als
bester deutscher auf platz sechs laufen
gold wohl der franzose konnte fiona je
silber geht an tarjei bö aus norwegen
und bronze holt eduard latif vom
russischen team
die deutschen biathletinnen in
aufsteigender form bleiben aber hinter
den erwartungen zurück die größte
aufholjagd gelingt vanessa hinz die von
platz 55 auf 21 fährt es gewinnt die
norwegerin marte als böse land
vorarlberg aus schweden und take off aus
norwegen
auch im riesenslalom der männer sorgte
der plötzliche unerwartete neue schnee
für missstimmung unter den athleten
viele der top fahrer schieden aus
darunter auch die deutschen alexander
schmid und linus straße schmid war die
ersten meter schnell unterwegs schneller
sogar als der spätere sieger dann aber
der rutsche und das frühe aus im ersten
durchgang
olympiasieger wurde der große favorit
warten auch ist der schweiz einziger
dsv-athlet heute im ziel julian
rauchfuss auf platz 20
an diesen neunten olympia tag gab es
noch andere entscheidungen auf eis und
schnee beachtlich dabei der fünfte platz
der deutschen langlauf staffel der
männer das und mehr jetzt kompakt mit
dem besten olympia ergebnis seit 2006 in
turin glänzt die deutsche langlauf
staffel der männer im schneetreiben von
jantscher kulanten janosch brugger
friedrich noch florian notz und lucas
bögl auf einem guten fünften platz gold
geht an das team aus russland vor
norwegen und frankreich
die deutsche eishockey-mannschaft
unterliegt den usa mit 2 3 und verpasste
so den direkten einzug ins viertelfinale
zu beginn gehen die deutschen sogar in
führung müssen sich dem starken us team
am ende aber geschlagen geben am
dienstag geht es ins play-off gegen die
slowakei bei der olympia premiere im
monobob der frauen liegt die deutsche
laura nolte auf medaillenkurs nach dem
ersten von zwei wettkampftagen sind nur
die us amerikanerin kelly humphries und
die kanadierin christine braun schneller
die zweite deutsche starterin maria
janka bisher mit schlingerkurs liegt
abgeschlagen auf rang 17
und in der fußball-bundesliga gewann der
bvb das erste sonntagsspiel 13 0 bei
union berlin das noch zur
vollständigkeit vielen dank hat ja
das wetter bot heute balsam für die
seele und das bleibt zumindest noch ein
bisschen so morgen ein meist
freundlicher sonnenuhr wollten nichts
von westen im tagesverlauf dichtere
wolken und zeitweise regen dazu im
norden ein kräftiger südwestwind an den
küsten mit stürmischen böen mild bei 7
bis 14 grad
das war es von uns hier geht es weiter
mit was nun herr steinmeier um viertel
vor zehn begrüßt sie christian sievers
im heute-journal wir sagen danke und
tschüss und wünschen ihnen einen guten
start in die neue woche was machen wenn
sie merken
[Musik]